en attendant que l'expert indépendant
termine son examen scientifique
je vais utiliser un arrêté d'urgence en
vertu de l'article 37 de la loi sur les
pêches afin de suspendre le projet alors
c'est denis lebel qui parlait pas son
nom ici parler au nom de la ministre de
l'environnement
alors mes trois panélistes sortie à la
question gay manon globensky une chaise
c'est logiquement somfy trottoir at-il
le choix en fait ce qu'on a l'impression
de comprendre et si c'est surtout pas le
déversement qu'avec électorat c'est
exactement si c'est exact c'est
exactement seul expert indépendant pour
prendre tout son temps
jusqu'au 19 octobre ça ils peuvent
rendre son rapport le plus rapidement
possible il ya pas de problème sauf que
c'est assez habile de la part de
monsieur lebel parce que personne va
accuser quelqu'un d'être prudent alors
quand on a vu les jeunes la réaction ne
s'observe que je pensais d'un seul chef
à réagir qui se bat oui c'est correct et
injuste et qui sont d'autres choses
victoria oratoire et dans un ace mais il
dit on a fait la chose prudentes alors
les personnes qui vont se sont objectés
de sang et ça donne le temps au
gouvernement d'aller chercher en fait le
risque c'était ne pas porter l'odieux
d'une décision comme ça c'est surtout
pas de décision bleus surtout pas de
décision mais en même temps en faisant
ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui ils nous font
oublier le fait que et dénis coderre
s'est apprécié de
dire tout début le gouvernement fédéral
environnement canada avait le dossier
entre les mains depuis un an
cette proposition elle était sur la
table et on n'avait toujours pas eu de
réaction comment se fait-il qu'on se
retrouve en campagne électorale à devoir
parler de ça et à devoir évoquer non
seulement environnement canada
mais la science parce que là on a
entendu denis lebel a plusieurs contrées
oui le beau scientifique est revenu au
moins six fois
voilà voilà alors grande conversion de
ce gouvernement là tout devient y ait
quelque chose de paradoxal avec ça parce
qu'on parle évidemment de donner mandat
des experts pour se pencher sur le sujet
savait qu'en 2012 à l'institut maurice
lamontagne qui est spécialisé sur l'eau
entre autres y avait en chaque chaire en
éco techs toxicologie du sénat y allons
couper huit des onze postes ligne le
gouvernement fédéral y en reste 3 alors
qu'ils en avaient 11 en a qui se
penchent exactement sur le type de
problèmes qu'on attendrait de soulever
alors on occupe des postes est pas très
important à l'époque le saint laurent et
le soudainement campagne électorale on
trouve ça très très important de
protéger les acheteurs
on en a plus beaucoup de postes au fil
des années au gouvernement on n'est pas
attendue aussi le maire coderre au tout
début du doigt aussi d'un savon fa il ya
deux trois semaines l'ancien et verse
nettement à dénis lebel
on s'est vite denis lebel allait faire
une annonce dans la journée on
connaissait pas encore la nature de
l'annoncé il avait dit j'espère forme
d'avertissement il j'espère qu'ils vont
pas faire de la petite politique sur ce
dossier
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
venant avec quelqu'un qui vous laissez
pas du tout ce que ça veut dire ça va
donner
je suis manager chez j'ai hâte de voir
sa réaction face à 17h à la fin il me
dira ce qu'il voudra lille 2 c et si
l'état campagne électorale comme il est
fait de la jupe un chiffre exactement
michel quand on vous avait soulevé la
réaction de monsieur duceppe on va
l'entendre justement parce qu'il soulève
de bonnes questions quand même jeunes en
même temps monsieur l'aube est d'avoir
la même attitude envers la ville de
toronto qui déverse chaque année 10
milliards d'aud usées dans le lac
ontario et la ville de victoria qui a
voix pour 30 milliards de litres d'eaux
usées dans l'océan pacifique à chaque
année alors ce centre d'appels à la
cohérence dans les décisions et d'être
conscients du précédent qu'on reste que
ici parce que quoi qu'il en soit même si
on repousse la décision il y aura il
vend seulement une décision si jamais le
fédéral se pose
il ya bien des gens qui vont l'attendre
dans le détour en parlant des autres
dossiers de tous les autres des
versements qui sont monnaie courante le
bailleur way disons qu'il ya d'autres
groupes qui s'opposent au déversement
des eaux usées
il peut seulement montréal à toronto une
vie active spots et environnemental
victoria en colombie-britannique du
cycle environnement c'est important
colombie-britannique donc le précédent
qu'on est peut-être en train de créer
pour montréal pour justement en pleine
campagne électorale pouvoir nous on
s'affiche comme étant protecteurs de
l'environnement
peu importe le gouvernement qui va être
la prochaine fois ça sera pas
nécessairement facile dans d'autres
villes mais je pense qu'il faut quand
même faire attention quand on parle de
deux précédents parce que d'alcool
montréal c'est quand même des versements
pendant quelques jours pour procéder à
certains travaux de construction alors
que dans le cas d'autres villes et on
peut même penser à un fax jusqu'à il n'y
a pas très longtemps c'est des
déversements donc qu'ils se font de
façon quotidien torontois ne parle pas
du tout du tout de la même chose
les curieux la peau du jeune homme aime
pas mais c'est ça alors il ya eu
finalement ça traduit aussi un manque de
volonté de vouloir investir dans des
équipements puis de changer complètement
son rapport à louer et à la loi sur les
pêches aussi nous là quelque part c'est
la sauce nombre d'amateurs les saillies
son brûlot de saint-antonin envoyé à
l'usiné d'épuration ce qui est encore
pire jusque là on n'a toujours pas eu la
réaction de monsieur coderre ce suspense
vraiment ce après midi on l'attendait à
16 la pression d'eau dit non petit peu
plus tard finalement s'est rendu à 18h
d'ailleurs on va le diffuser sur nos
ondes
pour monsieur coderre cc c'est aussi
important ce qui est en train de se
jouer sa réaction tout le monde latin
est-ce que c'est dangereux
actuellement pour le parti conservateur
de ce fait monsieur coderre ado parce
qu'on sait qui est un peu sanguin
on sait qu'il risque de faire une sortie
comment dire assez virulente
moi je dirais que ce moment si la
campagne c'est plus très important je
pense qu'on est on est passé au delà du
seuil justement parce que le fédéral
prend la décision de reporter sa après
l'élection
c'est fait c'est décidé c'est clos
combien de sièges les conservateurs mort
et 1 0 combien on a la grande région de
montréal 0 pour si l'éruption ses
convives ont gagné probablement 0 et
denis coderre était affichée du côté
libéral depuis plusieurs
les gens savent où j'allais oublier
évidemment le meilleur de tous les
montréalais mais les gens savent qui
était en politique active puisqu'il ya
pas très longtemps pour un parti qui le
parti adversaire donc à denis lebel je
pense que les gens sont capables de
faire la part des choses
alex est donc vous qui venez d'ouvrir
cette porte libéral alors on sent un
regain de confiance bien entendu à la
suite de tous ces nombreux sondages qui
sont tous allés vers la même direction
tranquillement pas vite
on peut écouter justement jeu s'inscrit
dès aujourd'hui est ce que je demande
les connaître aux canadiens de voter
pour nous oui est ce que je leur demande
de voter pour nous à travers le pays oui
est ce que je leur demande pour un
gouvernement majoritaire
oui alors il faut comprendre ici que ce
que vous avez vu c'est un court extrait
une longue longue longue réponse parce
que il utilise une très grande prudence
quand même dans cette demande d'avoir
une majorité elle ne se tenait il ya pas
balancer ça comme seul blanc dans une
réponse il la peur d'avoir l'air trop
confiants ou même un peu elle regarde
donc il dit il ya mis toute la série des
questions est ce que oui je sors oui je
sors bien sûr égouts et les chefs de
partis veulent avoir un gouvernement ne
méritais rien de mal à ça ce qui ce qui
nous vaut aujourd'hui avec les sondages
qu'on a vu depuis depuis 24 heures c'est
que jusqu'à jusqu'à ce jour là on ne
voyait pas la majorité possible
moi je pense pas qu'un tank hors
acquisitions des numéros de loin de là
mais elle est possible je dis pas que
c'est plausible je dispose est l'option
numéro 1
mais alors quand on voit la majorité
arrive et quand on est un chef de parti
bondi mais venez avec nous il ya
toujours bien sûr une espèce d'instinct
de deer valley avec le gardien c'est sûr
que monsieur trudel se développer mais
pas un danger aussi d'être un petit peu
trop confiants de leasing d'être maître
lui dit nous on est transparent c est un
peu comme ça que la question lui a été
pour vous aider vous aimez être
transparent alors dites-le nous y
arrivons après avoir mis trois paires
vigueur pour le dire il le 10 mai mais
il faut pas oublier que au départ les
libéraux se disait dépassant 100 sièges
cette fois ci le pouvoir à la prochaine
élection là on redonne complètement
dépassées ces scénarios lol si on se fie
à ce qu'on voit dans les sondages alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'en ce moment les gens qui étaient
prêts
revivre une vague orange ont remis tous
sont dans la balance 10 on est toujours
à la recherche du meilleur véhicule pour
éventuellement renverser un gouvernement
conservateur et plus on voit un chef
confiant plus on a envie de faire ce
choix là ça bouge encore beaucoup un
juge juste avant d'entrer en ondes en a
marre un sondage ekos 2006 en répondant
qu'il m'était que les libéraux et les
conservateurs sont en stagnation puis le
npd et a remonté de 4 points notamment
québec où il y aurait repris une avance
assez confortable je pense qu'encore
beaucoup de gens qui regardent s'il va
se passer et en os qui aime bien l'idée
d'avoir un gouvernement libéral
minoritaire sont pas nécessairement sous
de vouloir confier une majorité justin
trudeau les fameuses publicités il n'est
pas prix du parti conservateur dont il
était peut-être exagéré mais jusqu'à un
certain point il reflétait ce que les
conservateurs entendent et dans les
groupes de discussion exemple peut-être
qu'il est bien comme premier ministre
mais on pourrait le mettre sous
surveillance en minoritaire quelques
années peut-être avec la balance fois où
un [ __ ] l'un d'eux le voir impossible
terrain majoritaire et des gens qui vont
y réfléchir à deux fois donc la fin de
la course c'est pour ça que je t'ai être
devons être prudents stephen harper en
2006 avait fait un appel à se battre la
moitié pour moi un gouvernement
conservateur majoritaire
les gens a dit je pense certain qu'il
est venu et on n'y avait aucune manif
minorité il ya ce jour ce danger n 1
pour les libéraux s'il faut pas oublier
son or nous disent que plus du tiers des
électeurs décident de leur vote quand
ils ont le bulletin de vote entre 2010
avant c'était ballon on table le loup
rouge de café c'est chaud c'est plus le
cas et de plus en plus ça c'est pourtant
cette année la barre de spontané ou de
d'indécis jusqu'à la fin et déjà qu'ils
se décident à la fin alors est-ce que ça
ça joue du côté des gens qui disent moi
je vais majorité je peux retourner aux
aidants en élection dans 18 mois ou si
ça joue comme des attaques de l'autre
côté en dise à justin trudeau
majoritaire dans ce site un petit peu
trop peut-être voter npd cette fois ci
les deux sur bois c'est dommage parce
que c'est vrai et ça ne l'est pas quand
on prend une autre promesse qu'elle
québec et l'ontario je regarde les mêmes
sondages saison des échantillons
provinciaux sont plus faciles plus un
peu plus petits un peu moins fiables
mais quand même
en ontario on voit de plus en plus cette
course à deux une libérale versus
conservateur il ya qu'à voir la campagne
café stephen harper depuis le début de
la semaine
en particulier aujourd'hui blizzard ac
dessus bizarre on va avoir les ducs est
clean
ça c'est fait depuis le début de la
semaine annonce aujourd'hui on a appris
que samedi monsieur rhdp va participer à
un rallye à toronto organisée par les
frères ford qu'il ne veut pas nommer
qu'il ne veut pas nommer parce que on
lui pose la question les frères ford
était hier un événement de monsieur
harper dans la grande région de toronto
aujourd'hui ils annoncent qu'ils
organisent ce rallye pour samedi soir et
ont dit à monsieur nord peut vous
présenter un agenda un programme
électoral qui sévères contre la
criminalité et vous vous associez à
quelqu'un qui est un fumeur de crack
avoué alors bien sûr il a de la
difficulté à répondre à ça et il dit
cette famille sans la nommer des appuis
le parti conservateur depuis longtemps
alors c'est comme si c'était difficile
de s'en passer mais difficile de faire
avec
et hier par exemple il n'a pas serré la
main des frères ford quand il dit quand
il est en fait dans la salle et quand il
est sorti de la salle les frères ford
n'était plus là donc on ne les a pas vus
devant les caméras donc en somme les
vrais qu'on essaye de cacher la
formation par contre c'est peut-être
difficile le guen sont rendus les
conservateurs c'est difficile de dire
non décent plaisir la cause
conservatrice allait bien l'ontario il
serait pas avec les frères il ya besoin
de la formation le dernier bastion
conservateur dans la banlieue de toronto
ça montre quoi ça montre que ça chauffe
et manon raison dans les banlieues
toronto avec les libéraux que ça chauffe
il ya énormément de circonscriptions en
jeu ça vous montre les endroits où vous
stephen harper depuis maintenant qu'en
24 heures il est dans des situations
défensives dans des circonscriptions qui
sont conservées qu'elle est obligée de
faire le dernier samedi de la campagne
avec la base pur et dur c'est que ça va
pas bien on n'a pas besoin d' habitude
de convaincre les gens qu'ils n'échouent
et j'aimerais vous entendre sur une pub
qui est un petit peu particulière on va
leur montrer justement à l'écran se dire
des conservateurs l'objectif ici c'est
vraiment de cet accueil justin trudeau
alors pour marquer les langues les six
on vise une clientèle la minorité
ethnique on vise les gens qui
proviennent de chine il ya une version 6
1 gbe semble-t-il essentiellement une
produit les grandes lignes là on dit les
libéraux veulent légaliser la marijuana
faciliter l'accès donc de la drogue aux
enfants installé des centres d'injection
dans vos quartiers laissés des bordels
apparaître dans vos quartiers on voit un
peu
un peu comme ce qu'est ce que ça révèle
une plainte contre la tactique de
désespoir de la fin à une campagne d'une
certaine façon c'est comme si on se
disait qu'on peut te dis on peut faire
de la distorsion parce que bon ce sont
pas des mensonges mais c'est de la
distorsion de la réalité
nous avons dit bien ce qu'on veut dire
on s'en fout on s'adresse à des
communautés où on pense que ces choses
là vont résonner bien sûr mais même en
anglais on a envoyé des paquets de
papier à rouler dans des
circonscriptions dans les boîtes aux
lettres dans les circonscriptions
toronto pour dire juste m voici ce que
justin trudeau veut donner aux enfants
du papier pour nos monnaies serment de
l'associer à des dérives comme ça j'ai
envie de vous entendre sur une dernière
chose parce que le temps très très vite
comment vous réagissez quand vous
entendez par la suite mais seulement 15
questionné justement parce que lui-même
s'est positionné en faveur d'une
décriminalisation de la marijuana c'est
tout récent et quand on lui dit vous
allez faire comme justin trudeau il
n'empêche pas au courant qu'est ce que
ça révèle de jouer cette carte que la
décriminalisation de la marijuana on en
parle de plus de rapports de des relais
968 alors ce pas exactement une idée de
nouvelle dans le paysage politique
canadien là je connaissais bancaire
fasse semblant qu'ils sont pas au
courant des couverts je sais pas vous
mais moi je suis certain qu'il fait
semblant parce que la raison pour
laquelle les néo-démocrates et c'est pas
nouveau disent que justin trudeau a un
plan pour égaliser mais c'est pas
comment l'appliquer c'est qu'on a très
très peu de détails comment vont être
vendues à marijuana comment elle va être
contrôlé ce confort des taxes à ce que
c'est les provinces auront une société
d'état qui on vend de la marijuana
tous ces détails là ne sont pas connus
donc manqué peut-être la manière dont il
lui a répondu c'est un jeu peu courants
sont plaints s'était pas je ne sais pas
qui veut légaliser la marijuana s'est
plutôt ya tellement plus de détails
qu'on sait pas où il s'en va avec ça moi
c'est comme ce que les flux vers les
libéraux ont voulu faire les plus peur
qu'à pure et ne pas compter sur les
revenus provenant de marianne altérer
ses valeurs on peut penser qu'elle va
être taxés moi je suis comme ça mais je
m'en sers
j'ai mené ce temps il parle dans le rsa
pas trop fort que m6 était un oui merci
beaucoup à vous trois merci